ça ça fait de la peine d'avoir fait de
la peine à des des gens vraiment ça
c'est important tu le dis
comment va ta maman c'est gentil merci
ah oui parce qu'on l'avait vu triste à
l'époque comment elle va elle va bien
elle est contente que ça se calme un peu
tout ça pour toi elle est contente ouais
parce qu'elle avait très peu pour toi
ouais elle a toujours peur
est-ce que vous avez peur pour vous
avez peur un peu oui mais oui alors moi
en guise de conclusion je voudrais dire
que Benjamin
[Rires]
tout le monde a le droit à une seconde
chance je pense que ce serait bien que
vous puissiez faire des choses bénévoles
pour pour l'église de pouvoir faire des
choses pour pouvoir justement rattraper
ce que vous avez fait et je serai plus
vite non mais vraiment c'est vrai que
tout le monde a droit à une seconde
chance vous pouvez toujours faire des
choses positives je sais pas une
cagnotte un truc pour justement changer
ce truc et faire des choses pour
l'église de votre village Mathieu non
c'est bien hein sauf que et je ne t'en
voudrais jamais de ton honnêteté sauf
que j'ai le sentiment quand je t'ai posé
la question tout à l'heure et je te dis
est-ce que tu pourrais éventuellement le
refaire oui tu as un petit peu riche ça
veut dire qu'éventuellement tu pourrais
le refaire en fait
dans le futur c'est un truc tu dis pas
plus jamais tu dis tu pourras le refaire
non c'est pas prévu
il y a eu des rumeurs claire comme quoi
tu avais pensé à un moment à mettre fin
à tes jours est-ce que c'est vrai ouais
ouais ouais pourquoi
personne n'a envie parce que mon
quotidien était plus n'était plus fun
n'était plus fun je m'ennuyais enfin non
je vais parce que voilà ça c'est un buzz
voilà là
et que tu arrêtes de faire des vidéos
comme ça et tu reprends une vie normale
et que tu deviens sympathique et comme
tu es comme tu étais certainement avant
tout ça tu vas reprendre une vie normale
c'est moi quand j'entends que tu dis que
tu vas mettre fin à tes jours c'est pas
la solution la solution ce serait mais
on le sait tous quand on quotidien
devient trop compliqué
dans la vie à essayer peut-être les gens
voilà c'est c'est parce qu'on veut
entendre ça tu vas aller tu vas donner
raison à ceux qui t'ont harcelé en plus
donc ça c'est une connerie
tu t'es fait suivre ou pas depuis
finalement non
j'ai voulu aller en clinique pour me
faire interner
parce que apparemment j'avais pas de
j'ai pas eu de diagnostic en fait pour
me définir comme tu as envie de teint
interné pour je pensais que je pensais
que j'étais malade en fait je pensais
que j'étais fou je pensais que ça c'est
important qu'il fallait m'interner ou
quoi et finalement personne n'a voulu
m'interner donc
je suis resté chez moi j'ai réfléchi sur
moi-même et maintenant j'ai un psy aussi
qui met mais
ouais quand j'ai voulu vraiment être
aidé et être internet simplement je n'ai
pas été et j'ai trouvé mon injustice
aussi là dedans